[Musique]
un coeur jaune minutieusement découpé
dans un salon à montréal un coeur pour
symboliser la solidarité ces quatre
jeunes femmes ont toutes été victimes
d'agressions sexuelles
mélanie le mais n'avait que 17 ans
malheureusement je me suis retrouvé
piégé
cet esprit j'ai été sauvagement violées
j'ai pensé que j'ai à ce moment là que
j'allais mourir parce qu'ils essaient de
mettre angles avec mes clés elle est
devenue malgré elle le visage de la
lutte contre les violences sexuelles
c'est un meurtre de l'homme d'origine
agression sexuelle parce que moi
personnellement je serai jamais la fille
que j'étais avant le huard avant et un
après lapret a été difficile mais elle a
décidé de se battre
j'ai décidé de pouvoir devenir une voix
au québec et le mouvement mitu l'année
dernière n'a fait que renforcer cette
conviction
c'était il ya un an le mot-clic mitu moi
aussi en flammes les réseaux sociaux
guette
des milliers de femmes à travers le
monde affirme avoir été harcelés ou
agresser week end et soit à la une du
times celles et ceux qui ont rompu le
silence deviennent personnalité de
l'année 2017
mais la vague de dénonciations n'épargne
pas le québec qui la chute est brutale
pour les personnalités célèbres et
toutes les couches de la société sont
affectés ont fait publier la petite
éponge et préparer les demandes au
centre des dés de lutte contre les
agressions sexuelles se multiplient et
enfin 5 % d'augmentation des demandes
d'être mais vraiment au niveau des
ateliers de sensibilisation
on pense avoir rejoint près de quarante
mille personnes de plus cette année mais
seulement 5 % des victimes portent
plainte à la police
on dit aux femmes dénonce et aller de
l'avant aller voir la police tout sauf
que le problème c'est que seulement
trois cas sur 1000 qui avoue 6-1
condamnation si le procureur ne réussit
pas à démontrer au delà de tout doute
raisonnable qui a eu absence de
consentement vous avez plus d'affaires
ça veut dire qu'un juge regarde la
victime regardent l'agresseur et le peut
décider qui croient davantage la vie de
sable
mais si malgré tout il reste un petit
doute que peut-être l'agresseur qui dit
la vérité il doit acquitter
mais on revient de loin nous dira
chaignon d'un très lourd passif par
rapport aux crimes de l'agression
sexuelle qui est devenu un crime très
tard dans l'histoire du canada et qui
est devenu un crime où on a admis le
témoignage des victimes
à partir des années 80 seulement jusque
dans les années 80 il fallait un témoin
aujourd'hui les mentalités ont changé
mais pour beaucoup l'impunité demeure ni
à une veille sociale
bon ben qu'est ce qu'on va faire
concrètement pour que l'on puisse
changer la façon dont le traitement des
plaintes des victimes est accueilli et
on avait besoin à l'époque
pourtant très avoir un courage que fait
le cored mélanie elle distribue des
coeurs jaune pour sensibiliser la
population sur la question
elle a porté plainte contre son
agresseur il ya deux ans et son dossier
toujours en attente
on vient d'ouvrir une boîte de pandore
qui a été réprimée pendant des siècles
et des siècles et des siècles
c'est pourquoi on le présente en terrain
connu on sait pas où ça va à lui ce qui
est important de mettre en place
certaines barres use pour que ça puisse
continuer de grandir et non pas que ça
devienne une anomalie historique
[Musique]